ah hello there morning at least morning
here whatever the time is wherever you
are and welcome to another of these
sessions where I share some of my
experience what I'm going through in my
90 day challenge and try to answer some
questions or you have an opportunity to
make your comments about your own
experience but today the theme is the
importance what I consider the
importance of being random in language
learning and this King to me is sort of
maybe I'll just describe what I'm doing
so first of all this 90 day challenge
for me you know Arabic and Persian he's
actually a lot of work I'll be happy you
know what I left that open secret in
there but it just kind of looks messy um
so yeah it's a lot of work so half the
week is in person half the weeks in
Arabic so I'm not progressing as quickly
in the one or the other as I would like
however it keeps things fresh keeps me
motivated like right now I'm into Arabic
and I have in fact a conversation with
an Arabic tutor and in a couple of days
I'll switch back to Persian and there
are things that I'm looking forward to
doing each of those languages so one of
the things I've started doing now in
bowls he's I've gone back to my house
email course and I'm reading through
with the book each chapter and I'm
looking at all of the grammatical notes
now the first time through reading those
grammatical explanations it makes very
little impact on me
because there's too much information
everything is too new to try and Arabic
to understand how the verbs change
according to the person according to
male-female you know plural to make a
female to male and female plural all of
this stuff is simply too much
information and
and there are other examples in in
Persian but now having had enough
exposure to both of those languages I go
through the book I'm up to less than 45
or 50 account remember and each one of
them I know all the words I have
experienced a lot of the things that
they're talking about through a lot of
the listening and reading that I've been
doing and so now it's it's very
reinforcing to see these explanations to
understand these explanations to confirm
some of the things you've seen to point
out some things that you may not have
noticed and so I began to realize that
so that was one thing so I realized that
you know we often people say well I want
to learn the basics first when you can't
learn the basics first you kind of have
to like language itself is random when
they say you know immersion is the best
strategy if you're in an emergent
situation you have no control over what
aspect of the language is gonna come at
you whether they will teach you the
basics first certainly won't get exposed
to ten colors upfront it just comes at
you in the way it comes at two different
tenses different items of vocabulary and
so I think and I find that that's
important to have a realization of that
when we learn languages that that it's
kind of scrambled and to accept it as
scrambled and to deal with it in a
scrambled way first get some words going
get used to hearing it get used to
reading it a bit get used to struggling
it struggling with it read the are
dramatically explanation and forget it
but then at a later stage it's kind of
good to go back and go over some of the
lessons with the explanations that you
did earlier and which are a bit of a
blur to you
similarly with my playlist you know
typically on my playlist we're at link
we're limited to 100 in it they are
looking at things that are gonna make
the playlist a little more flexible for
users but typically in any you know
course that I have I listen to less than
150 times and by the time I get the
lesson
30 or 40 I'm only I'm only does in ten
times so and I hadn't realized and Mark
pointed the duck to me that I can send
everything to random to to stew yeah
shuffle rather shuffle so then it
becomes random so then I have a better
chance of listening an equal amount to
all of these different lessons so
therefore but I can set it back to
repeat as well I don't have to set it I
can keep it on shuffle for a while but
then if I want to go through the whole
course from a to Zed or 1 to 25 then I
can set it for that as well so there
again random is a good thing when I look
at my approach to flashcards you know
there are those who are completely
committed into a sort of a spaced
repetition system like Anki I don't I do
review you know my flashcards see
different activities but I do it again
on a random basis because if I were to
commit to reviewing all of the words
that I have learned in some kind of a
spaced repetition system that would eat
up all the time I have available for
language writing so I ask sippy I'm not
going to do that if I were spending
eight hours a day you know I'm like when
I was learning Chinese where I was
literally studying six seven hours a day
I think I would have set aside an hour
every day for you know an antitype
spaced repetition review but when I have
an hour and a half to two hours and I
want to listen and I want to read I'll
throw in a little bit of random review
particularly a vocabulary you know right
after having read something so there
again random flashcards random listening
again if I'm listening on the playlist
to me in a way listening is the main
activity as president in most of my time
if I listen to something and I don't
understand that then I can go to the
playlist and I can open that lesson and
I can read it and review the words again
so that the listening is kind of driving
me to do other things and so randomizing
it is kind of good because then I'm
getting
random like I'll get curious and here's
something you didn't really understand
of that well I go to my iPad
I click on the lesson open it up and
read it so that again randomizing is
giving me random access to different
bits and pieces of the language which is
what happens in an emergent situation or
watching a movie you have no control
over what's gonna come at you so you can
be systematic I think to some extent
particularly in reviewing earlier
lessons and and any lesson that you have
ever done whether it be in a book or a
link is a friend you have that you can
go back to it and should go back to it
over and over and over again and you can
go back to it in a totally random way
nothing wrong with that it's not as if
what was covered in less than three
needs to be covered before you have the
lesson five the language is like that
you can do less than five less than 15
less than three less than eight the I
don't find that there's necessarily any
progression it's not obvious to me like
typically in most languages they try to
teach you the present tense first but in
Arabic and I think in purge and I think
that was also good to know maybe not a
person but in Arabic they begin with the
past tense because the past tense is
easier in Arabic but there's nothing
intrinsically more difficult about the
past tense than the present tense
eventually you have to learn them all so
you can learn them in any order you want
you can learn randomly so so I think to
have an approach which says I'm not
building this is not like building
blocks once I sock this into place and I
can build this other stuff on top of it
I don't see it that way at all you're
catching little bits and pieces of the
language forgetting it meeting it again
some things click in and then you lose
them again some other things click in so
that I think an attitude of of
randomness which then keeps things fresh
because you're dealing with new stuff
and jumping around and just allowing the
language to through stimulate your brain
and the brain was already know the grit
rain will collect all these different
pieces and put them together we
enough stimulus and maybe the variety
makes it more stimulating for the ring
so it's a I mentioned that because
typically in language courses they try
to say you got every lesson one of us do
and if you go ahead the lesson five the
teacher tells you don't go ahead of the
class I haven't explained that to use as
the teacher
well maybe the explanation will quickly
be lost in any case and that the the
student needs to be aware that that
lesson 2 lesson 3 they gotta go back
there again and again on their own and
they shouldn't be a relying on the
teacher to lead them through lessons 1 2
3 4 5 in the hope that somehow they'll
end up with something because it'll just
collapse like a castle in the sand you
know in the next wave washes in so
anyway just to say that at least in my
own experience I find an attitude which
which not only accepts the random nature
of an attorney but embraces it and makes
the language running random in the end I
think we'll be more successful than one
that tries to be systematic no that's my
experience my view I look forward to
your views and so with that I'm gonna
have a look at whatever questions and
comments we have so let me just see here
whatever you got all right how are you
guys doing there's only a lot of nice
chit chat yes I was late you know
Edwin Finch sorry I was a minute or two
late I was cleaning up after breakfast
yes definitely I get up first I made
some porridge fruit salad and stuff and
then we watched a bit of television i
watch the the aftermath of the Chamizal
in the united states then I opened my
iPad and looked up my you know podcasts
and so there was a tremendous podcast
from across venkat about Egypt and
ancient Egypt and Egyptology mystery
Kadima and I was understanding 10 15 20
% of
so I immediately went in and in fact
I'll show you that just for the fun of
it I went in to you know I grabbed hold
I grabbed a hold of the grab the whole
of the the video file popped it on my
mp3 converter to content convert it to
mp3 then I put it into my vocal Matic
I'm not sure it's still up here yeah
vocal Matic I have to go in and remove
all the times the timestamps but once I
have that I can copy it and import it
into link then I go to my I have saved
my mp3 conversion of the file to the
desktop so I can import that and I now
have a lesson on link which I have
entitled Egypt March from five I put it
in my pasta cat course and I'm ready to
go so there's a bunch of blue words
there's some yellow words there's some
white words and I just can't wait to do
it and it's a full I don't know 30 40
minutes long so this will keep me going
for a while so between that and cleaning
up and everything else I was busy and
there was a couple of minutes late so I
apologize and so again you can see how
things are random like so I've got this
material to go through which is
difficult and you're not going through
my essay hill lessons which are easy but
confirming some of the things that I've
noticed about you know grammar and so
yeah there you have it no let's get back
so yes sorry I'm late
200 days in a row link Street currently
ranked number four very good grades from
Virginia alright Virginia I have never
been to Virginia I've been to Myrtle
Beach that's North Carolina made I've
been to Washington DC once it was very
nice it's actually snowing I renew money
because it actually worked here that I
was just reading your book
popped up high from Florrie I hope you
don't think I'm sure cuz I read
delicious okay America's delusional
yesterday we live in this community here
and so a bunch of people decided we were
all gonna go out and tailgate at the
local polo match here in conference and
I'm tellin ya everybody chipped in
brought food that's a few Canadians as
well but you know chairs tents tech
canopies to sit under it was a fabulous
fabulous day everybody very helpful and
cooperative we like Peter
don't worry thanks after learn Chinese
you could make Oh blah blah blah
Japanese Genda know which language what
are the languages to learn if you live
in the US in terms of managing if you
don't learn languages to make money okay
the approach to learning languages is
the following in life and I can talk a
little bit because I'm older now
whatever success you want to achieve in
life is a function of how many
opportunities you're able to take
advantage of so in order to have
opportunities come your way you have to
do something if you sit on your hands
and do nothing
there will be no opportunities if you're
up doing stuff helping people giving
things to people that's gonna trigger
opportunities coming your way if you
learn things if you work somewhere are
you volunteer and if you learn a several
languages you are gonna increase the
number of opportunities that may come
your way and that's it so that
opportunity might come in Spanish it
might come with Chinese it might come
with our victim might come with Russian
so I don't think he's trying and again
life is a bit random too it's not
because you do step one that you will
necessarily get to step two if you do
step one it might trigger something that
you hadn't even anticipated that will
come your way
non language learning related book
recommendations well it's hard like I
can't remember right now some of the
interesting books that I've read but I
like to read about history and so my
recommendation would be
the lines of history but I right off the
bat here trying to answer everybody's
question I can't immediately think of I
can't immediately think of books to
recommend Oh Baba what do you think some
people just tell you to do something
else because they tell you learning
language is useless
okay I've dealt with that learning life
okay in life okay so I thought about
when we went to the Polo Grounds well
someone had to come up with the idea of
organizing an excursion to the Polo
every year in Palm Springs everybody had
to do something everybody was doing
stuff doing something constructive if
you do something constructive you will
be happy and you will be contributing to
other people's happiness so just do
stuff if you want to learn a language to
learn a language that's something
constructive just do things that are
constructive and good things will happen
what's the very first thing you do when
you stumble across a new word me
personally I look it up on you know I
click it up pops up possible you know it
could be a user end it could be Google
Translate or whatever if I like it I
take it if I don't like it I go to the
dictionary very often in Arabic I go to
context reversal it's very good there
was another one I can't remember
anyway I added another Persian
dictionary as well so I checked around
if I don't like the I don't like the you
know sometimes I don't like the the
dictionary definition that I get so then
I find a better is in our speaking
online with a tutor equal in value to an
hour talking with someone in person very
good question
pluses and minuses it depends entirely
on the person or tutor you're talking to
obviously language learning
it relies on certain from resonance like
if you talk to someone that you like him
where there's strong resonance you're
gonna do better you're gonna retain more
if you are face to face with someone
it's higher resonance than being online
on the other hand online has the
advantage that you
the report if I were to say would I
rather sit down with someone for an hour
or two rather go online with someone for
an hour I'd rather sit down in person in
terms of accents what language is the
most difficult for you
I mean there are aspects of Arabic that
are quite difficult like that oh I still
haven't figured about it
there are things in Swedish that are
difficult there are things in French
rush I mean there are sounds in
different languages that are difficult I
wouldn't I can't really say in terms of
generalization hmm
hey Steve what would you say is your
third best language other than English
and French Japanese definitely followed
by Mandarin Chinese followed by Spanish
privyet Steve period yeah and I'd love
to go back to Russia sometime will hey
Steve do you think it's important to
sleep more every night when you're
learning a language sleeping is good if
you don't sleep well you have less
energy you are not as positive so but
that's true for any activity hello Steve
have you ever seen anyone reach
native-like fluency and accent in
Spanish Thank You negative light but if
you take the answer is not only in
Spanish but in other languages like
there's - ah who lives in China
apparently like I can't judge someone as
to whether they're native or not in any
language other than English okay because
however good their accent is if you're
not a native speaker you don't know but
I think that Luca and perilla in Spanish
sounds native to me he would be one that
comes to mind but then his native
languages Italian and he lived in Spain
so that gives them some advantages how
to start a new language when you don't
know a single word that's what link is
all about you start with short pieces
you look up the words you listen you go
away and listen on your playlist you
listen again you read again you review
the words and slowly slowly you get a
bit of a grip on the language with
lesson 1 and even before you understand
all of us and wine
lesson two in lesson three and listen
for and by the way not in the sense that
lesson one prepares you for lesson two
it's just that you get tired of lesson
one and you move on lesson two okay now
huh thank you when you learn a new word
you take any effort to try to remember
to order you just go with the flow and
just use exposure for the word to sort
of naturally hold gain some place in
your memory yeah I don't make any
particular effort I don't in fact I have
no expectation that I will remember it
I'm not at all disappointed when I don't
remember at the second the third time
I'm just curious
in fact as to how many times I will have
to sneak that word before it stick yes
and so I just continue with the exposure
on link I can move it from you know sort
of category one word which is the dark
yellow to two to three I'll often do
that I'll often do that just in order to
help me notice the word so even though I
you know I've now seen it once or twice
I'll just move it to two even though I
don't really feel confident that I have
a better grasp of that word I'll just
move it to two anyway I like to lighten
up the color on my page and then in time
I realized that I now know this word and
so then I move it to known Steve again I
come into some random YouTube video and
one of the guys in that comment said you
told me to work on my weak English and
this made me disappointed nervous and
hopeless there are first of all based on
what you've written here your English is
not weak second of all there are people
who take pleasure in sort of again
random random nastiness on social media
my advice is to ignore them I ignore
them people come on my youtuber you're
boring you're a big windbag they tell me
well that's fine so then you know that
person probably won't why does he even
bother coming on my channel to tell me
how bad my videos are go somewhere else
don't worry about it
you will learn languages for ourselves
we learn languages because of the
tremendous enjoyment we get from you
know realizing that we're understanding
more and more of the leg
that we can communicate in the language
that earlier we couldn't communicate in
and so therefore you know I wouldn't get
too carried away when people will tell
you that you're doing well and I
wouldn't get disappointed when people
tell you that you're angry just no good
basically you know how well you're doing
they somehow well you understand and
slowly the sense that you're better able
to expect that's yourself although the
progress there is sometimes that's slow
there what are your thoughts I'm trying
to practice people every day well sure
you can find people to practice with
every day that's great and it also
depends on your ability to fit that into
your schedule ah max no just remember
that that guy's problem
I agree with Russian with Max absolutely
have you ever seen someone speak C to
Russian that isn't a native Slavic
language speaker or I haven't heard that
many non-native speakers of Russian but
I am sure as with every language I am
sure that such people exist in fact if I
hear people speak Russian well and
particularly if they nail a cases or the
you know the aspect of verbs I'm just
very very impressed but always I can
hear the ones that I've heard that
they're not made so I but I'm sure such
people exist I can't think of anyone off
the bat I just bought a book about
learning multiple languages in scratch
at the same time what's your opinion
about thanks about Alexander from Brent
well I in my case I haven't done it
because I started with Arabic and then
having learned the Arabic the Arabic
alphabet I thought I would take
advantage of that to learn pers was
liberating both necessary from scratch
but my advice and all this stuff is do
it and experiment with it languages are
used to be fun
and therefore you know random and do it
and but you'll see that you may want to
favor one language because you're more
interested in it or you want to maybe
continue both because you have a gives
you a sense of variety and you look
forward to spending a little
hear them there you might do as I'm
doing you know half the week on one and
half the week on the other you may go
two weeks on one and two weeks on the
other you may decide to go 80% on one
and 20% on the other tournament with it
nothing bad is gonna happen
quranic for contents can end up
confusing our brain no no I
okay not in my experience don't try to
master one role for me in language
learning is don't think that you can
master anything because you won't in my
view and in my experience and therefore
yeah you can deal with contents in
different ways I move on when I don't
understand you know if I want to
understand 60 70 % it's time for me to
move on if I find that content
uninteresting if I don't like the voice
I move on I try to stay mostly in
content which is not too difficult for
me spot when there's no more of that
stuff no more of a sort of early
intermediate material that I should be
doing in Arabic then I move into more
difficult content such as this material
on Egypt that I'm looking forward to
attempting mm-hmm you think linguists
can learn language faster because they
know the science of languages no I think
that if that linguistics has very little
to do with language when I come in Steve
like video I see logic painful Naruto I
think so here in our group we don't have
too many nasty people I haven't come
across
do you enjoy making these life strings I
enjoy making these live streets I
enjoyed the reaction I enjoy the
questions I mean Here I am the whole
language learning thing is kind of my
third career I enjoy learning the
languages I enjoy talking to people
about languages I was learning I would
like more people to learn and I'm always
sort of bit annoyed when I hear people
say yeah I would like to learn a
language but I don't have the talent
you're lucky you have the talent okay
but I am quite committed to language
learn okay Neha from Shenyang how to add
time material we don't have time right
now so there are people who use some
other language slot that they're never
going to use like Latin and import
material in some other language becomes
a little difficult because you have to
find an online dictionary for that we
don't support the language also we don't
want people doing that so much because
then someone who is studying Latin will
find you know Thai I don't know it is
hopefully someone will help us produce
the mini stories in Thai and then we
will have Thai a lot of session you're
looking for another kind of learning or
their website check it out I like the
idea of company however I find it hard
to retain vocab I have read I can
realize what it means in a sense I read
it again but hard when it appears
somewhere else okay of course we can't
remember vocab don't expect to retain
vocab just focus on enjoying the content
and understanding the words in that
context and if you don't understand them
lock them up with your online dictionary
or whatever it randomly review them and
you will find all of a sudden as the
example I showed with my when I shared
my screen of that Egyptian that
phosphide cat podcast
I had described and I had imported as a
lesson lots of white spaces eventually
the words do stick but you can't
deliberately learn them any test for
getting used to Japanese grammar I tried
I tend to over analyze syntax it's not
the meaning of everywhere never said
sorry yeah don't try to understand
everything it's you know slowly slowly
the fog lifts so when you first start
out in a language especially especially
a language like Japanese which is the
logic of Japanese is quite different
from the logic to say French and so you
sometimes think like that can't possibly
be how the language works or that
doesn't make sense because we're using
our you know Western language logical
system to try to understand the language
and so you think you'll never get used
it in fact you get used to it and I
don't find that the grammatical
explanations help a lot only when you
have already gotten used to the language
do and then at that point of the
grammatical explanations which confirm
what you have experienced do they then
make sense so I learned Japanese without
any kind of grammatical explanations
just in Japanese they say things this
way okay so that gets it through the
content but then you can use it and the
next time you encounter that structure
you're still confused but with enough
exposure these things start to become
natural
do you read out louder in your head I
think all of us when we read in a
foreign language we read in our head we
some vocalize I don't do a lot of
reading out loud but I am saying the
words in my brain for sure
hello from Bahrain hello
okay no no no okay if you don't you know
novels are difficult this is from
Navarro selling selling daddy's more
okay for a second about saying no no say
you don't mean our Nova
normals novels are difficult very
difficult lots of more difficult
vocabulary than news articles and it's
longer so to take on a novel the reading
of non novel is a major challenge but
once we have read a novel it's a major
milestone in your learning so you know I
would begin by reading novels like I
would go over novels where I can find
the audiobook and then I would import
the novel into link and I'd go through
an acquired vocabulary and I'd listen to
it and I would also get the paper book
and then I would read it in the paper
and if I did do that for a couple of
novels that then will get me ready to
just go and read a novel without the
help of the audio how can I create an
environment for English well I don't
know where you are but you know there
are line language online language
exchanges and and I mean it's great to
talk but actually you can do a lot just
by listening and reading I want to
continue to stress that hello I'm from
Indonesia we now have Indonesia netlink
for those of you who are interested in
learning Indonesian one day I'm a and at
that point doing mom on may help me is
there any news on the link t-shirts
I spoke to mark he's sexy on leave and
holiday for two weeks we're looking at
what we can do he has a friend who is
into sort of promotional clothing items
and we will get back to you then two
times the same time where it would work
with the English language well I mean it
depends what you're interested in
there's nothing you know you can learn
English and French you can learn English
and Chinese
okay Costa Rica I should visit country
got my wife
her father was Chinese her mother was
Costa Rica so we do have a connection
with Costa Rica my kids have visited
Costa Rica I will let you know if I come
I'm going us for three months from
working are there some tips for me to
develop English well I would you know do
as much as you can before you get there
lots of listening and reading movies you
know novels audiobooks because the
better your level when you arrive the
better you will be able to take
advantage of the three months that you
are in the US okay yeah I understand
most the books but TV still is very
difficult of course TV series are
difficult a lot of the sort of scenarios
and these TV series are not very natural
but language sometimes is not very
natural it's difficult to understand
them you're not in the situation if
you're actually in amongst people you're
in it the TV thing you're not in it I
found those difficult in Japan after
even five years living in Japan even
though I could conduct business very
well in Japanese do you think language
teachers in school don't really care if
you learn the language or not oh no they
care no question I have been to the
these American conference for the
teaching foreign languages convention is
that they have and the teachers are very
enthusiastic
I just think very often the methods that
they use that are typically imposed by
the curriculum by the school system are
not so effective but most teachers very
much care if you learn teachers are very
motivated to help their students that's
been my experience have you heard of a
read lang it's a website similar I've
been using it for I'll improve my
Russian Portuguese
no have you ever met you did it no
greetings from Colombia I've been
reading your book the language the link
in French thank you for sharing thank
you greetings from illa solvent
ignore you when you try to speak the
native language you know there's no
accounting for what how people will
react when you speak their native
language they're not your teacher so
they're not going to humor you if they
speak to you in the language that you're
learning good and if they don't then you
just have to communicate with them in
whatever language seems to work the best
I agree how does intensive reading work
in our brains how does it help to
achieve fluency
well alright I'm not entirely sure what
intensive there's sort of intensive
reading and extensive reading I tend to
call intensive reading the kind of stuff
that I do at link where I read and I
look up words and I listen and I listen
again and I read again that's very
intensive whereas extensive is not to
worry about words you don't know and
this is something you can do as you
progress in the language and so you're
covering more material there's more gaps
words that you're kind of leaving aside
and but you're reading more extensively
in both cases they have the effect of
providing stimulus to the brain so that
the brain gradually gets used to the
language that's all I can say about how
it works because I am NOT a
neuroscientist when reading Persian and
then you suddenly come across a French
word does this make you happy yeah I got
a freebie CAD or magazine or whatever
plus but even more so when I come across
Arabic words so anytime this is this
thing about all friends I love false
friends there's all kinds of stuff on
the internet you know teachers fussing
about false friends friends be careful
it doesn't necessarily mean the same
thing that may be true but in terms of
helping you remember vocabulary those
words that are similar to words and
other languages
even if they have a somewhat different
meaning are very helpful and always
welcome I am stuck at the b2 level
terrible Plateau since one year in
German and the advice huh if you're a b2
you're in the sweet spot okay I would
love to go back to all my be two
languages and just enjoy them read and
listen and speak when I get an
opportunity and because I wouldn't be
enjoying the language I've done all the
hard work
myself to be - now I'm gliding and as I
continue gliding I will slowly slowly
improve I would also maybe if there are
certain structures in the language that
continue to give me trouble I would pay
a special you know attention to them I
would underline them while reading or
save them as phrases if if I'm in link
to try to get at those areas where I
know that when I speak I kind of
struggled to say those things that's all
but in the meantime just enjoy the
language if you arm wrestled awesome who
will win and he will win his life games
are awesome I learned so much okay thank
you Sophia because I like it how is it
how is it going he's gonna how can I
learn any language that feeling that I'm
losing progress in languages that I
already learned
I never feel that I honey I could not
now speak Romanian okay but I have done
enough in Romanian or Greek that if I
all of a sudden had to visit Romania or
Greece and I have well I have a lot of
stuff material in link that I have
already studied I would go over that
again
so these languages are not gone there's
somewhere in your brain and in my case
is somewhere in my iPad in my link
system and I just refresh them and they
come back and very often I have found
that when I go back to a language that I
did before so I'm rusty for three days
but when I come back I am stronger than
I was before and it's because we forget
and we relearn and we end up knowing it
better so I wouldn't worry about it
does polish help you learn Russian or
would it be more helpful for Russian to
help you learn polish I mean it goes
both ways
polish in a way is easier because it's
written in the Latin alphabet and I find
that's always it's always easier to read
in the language in the alphabet there
you're most familiar with but I think
either one is going to help you because
uh in all of the Slavic languages that I
have not and the fundamental grammatical
issues are the same
so I mean the question here is no matter
yeah you say it's not important to
master content you mean for those who
are just learners who like languages or
is it also those who intend to work as a
teacher okay if you intend to work as a
teacher you want to be competent in the
language I believe that not worrying
about math trying to master stuff is
going to get you to fluency faster if
you try to master a limited amount of
content you won't master it anyway and
you will slow down your progress so I
would say that if the goal is to be
fluent in the language for whatever
reason including you know the desire to
work as a teacher then don't be too hung
up about mastery stuff however if you're
gonna teach the language then you do
have to do what I'm now doing in my
Arabic and Persian in other words having
you don't worry about mastering the
language you charge for it but every so
often you have to go back and go over
these sort of basic grammar explanation
the the you know the the beginner book
the basic stuff you don't do the Bey the
best time to do the basics is when
you're already quite advanced in the
language and then you go back and every
time you do and more than once and every
time you do that you get a firmer and
firmer grasp on the basics but you can
only start to grasp the basics after you
have moved forward without worrying
about the basics if that makes sense
thank you yeah yeah that's right no I
mean not ever gonna like my my in my
videos and those that do watch and those
that don't don't don't reason but I have
no problem with be two speakers I've
seen a personage do you think learning
phrases every day is a good way to
ensure learning learn phrase is good
to mini-story provided by AJ Hoge but
still my English hasn't improved much I
mean one shouldn't continuously
criticise one's own level or level of
improvement
i I I would guess that your English
probably has improved but you can also
just stay with simple stories you've got
to get up a right idea of content
because you know the brain requires
repetition but the brain requires
novelty so you have to stimulate the
brain so don't just stay with the same
kind of content again gets back to this
whole random thing make sure you get
over right baby of content open things
out for the brain
keep it fresh for the brain you think
going to a country for three months will
increase your level if you are a - I
can't answer that that depends on so
many different factors
selamat pagi haha say yeah okay I don't
think I see I didn't think I see you
Greek is more difficult more intriguing
I'm an old okay okay not very sees huh
do you have any tips for learning French
verbs from text I usually can't tell
whether they are regular irregular or
how they are formed with different
persons okay so if you're on link and I
refer to that because I think that's a
particularly you know useful but it
needn't be just linked there are
dictionaries out there conjugating
dictionaries and so if I look up a word
it linked then I go to that conjugating
dictionary context reversal for example
and you so then I look so I look at this
verb so the verb says you know whatever
it is
Jovie so I look up if I click on it
it'll show me that it comes from LA to
go and it'll show me all of the
different conjugations of that verb and
I just looked through it very briefly I
looked for the one that I selected and
all the other conjugations and I go back
to my text it's just again sort of a
random exposure to that verb and every
time I come across a verb or I have any
doubts I go to that conjugating
dictionary and to confirm just where it
is where it fits in and some of the
other stuff and after a while it's just
random exposure to the language you can
be exposing yourself to the language in
a context Unix
close yourself to the language in these
tables and it's all gradually gonna help
okay I think you learn in Iran you need
to be a fan of tea blowing in the
Reading Series by the way greetings from
Turkey I'm learning nine languages I'm
wondering how can I study all those
languages at the same time I have no
idea that's a lot I find that I'm very
busy trying to learn two languages and
fitting in all the other activities that
I have do you turn people off you speak
to proper no I don't think so what do
you think an online language tutor
should do I think an online language
tutor role number one is to be very
encouraged okay so to motivate the
learner show no impatience when the
learner makes the same mistake over and
over again try to stay in the target
language as much as possible repeating
things picking up on the phrases that
the learner didn't use correctly keep
the conversation going don't rely on the
learner don't try to say well what do
you want to talk about today they
learned it doesn't know the learner is a
little tense
doesn't necessarily you know isn't in a
position to lead with the language so
you have to bring the language out of
the learner try and find areas of the
learner is comfortable talking about and
and so encouraging stimulating
motivating obviously a good Skype
connection good lighting sometimes I
talk to people it's so dark whenever you
can do to make it a pleasant experience
and then to end up with a good list of
fifteen phrases that the learner
struggled with and ideally record those
and then send them off as a report Steve
is reading we're listening good or is
really more effective it's all good I
find that demand I'm not very strong in
a language it's very difficult for me to
read as quickly as the audio so I tend
to read which takes me longer because
I'm looking at words I'm struggling to
read and then I go away and listen but I
also occasionally will listen to reason
yeah I mean these are the thing this is
you know we have to make decisions about
where to spend our time nine languages
is a lot if you in your expert opinion
what are the easiest language learn
don't know blah blah blah
tea can you give tips on how to use
listening how to listen or what to
listen to
well I listen when I'm doing other
things I cannot just sit down and listen
if I sit down and listen I lose focus
maybe it's because I'm fidgety and
impatient so if I'm cleaning up the
kitchen if I'm exercising if I'm in the
car that's when I listen because I'm
listening while doing other things I've
paid in a note so and I could be
listening to say too many stories that I
listen to before in order to focus in on
certain aspects of the language that I
hadn't noticed I can only do that for so
long before I completely lose focus if I
must listen to something that's
intrinsically interesting like a novel
or an audio book or interview on France
podcast which I don't understand yet
then I'm listening for content and I'm
still kind of in and out so don't worry
about it just listen you fade in and out
it's just exposure and ideally if you
don't understand it all you go to the
text and read it and save words and
phrases so you'll have a better chance
to understand it the next time hello
from algae if he mister coughing thank
you Anna sighs to see you thank you as
well what is the topic today it's the
random nature of language learning how
can I improve tones while speaking
Japanese Chinese tones in Chinese you
can learn them as phrases it's difficult
to remember the individual tones and I
my own experience was that when I
started listening to Xiao Chun these
comic dialogues in Chinese because they
exaggerate the tones that very much
helped resale recipe Lister cellphone
either your English will improve with
you is more emojis tada
check that judge and I practice and
you'll get accepted is it worth doing
flash cards for the readings of Japanese
words are letting emerge and fill-in the
meaning well I didn't do flash cards
I started Japanese already knowing the
Chinese characters for Chinese and I
didn't use flash cards in Japanese so I
can't say if it's used for not I think
people have to try different things and
see what works for them ok in learning
allowing for the tutor versus tandem
language exchange I have never been a
big fan of tender language exchange I
you know I'm selfish I want to learn the
language I don't really want to speak
English but again depends on the partner
just as the tutor depends on who the
tutor is if you have a very good person
and you have interesting things to talk
about both of you but both in your own
language and the target language I'm
sure it would be a very good thing to do
instead let's just admit Japanese is the
hardest language for native speakers of
indo-european languages I have not found
that to be the case I know many say
English teachers you go to Japan and end
up speaking Japanese very very well lots
of good speakers of Japanese I don't
think it's that difficult I mean I
shouldn't say that it's not difficult
but to say that is much more difficult
than anything else I don't believe that
there are issues you learn the kana
which is not a big problem govern the
kanji which is a bigger problem but
dramatically it has I don't think it's a
big deal but that's up to each
individual I heard steam crash today you
know in five to ten percent of a word
every time you read it does your brain
learn words like that when you are
listening yeah I don't I'm not so
confident of how much you learn about a
word every time you read it or hear it
some words simply click in faster other
words forever you seem unable to
remember them yeah I simply don't know I
simply don't know
should you take advisor millennia to
tell you see the way to learn language
because you know that's up to you homer
in link more than reading in my native
language thank you so much really here
most welcome
can you give me tips and ideas listening
I we answered that any plans to learn
Latin I had at a school it's not the top
of my list when will you have a living
video at Russian with Max sure we can do
that where are you from Steve I grew up
in Montreal but I live in Vancouver most
of the time do you think to beginners in
each other's languages should learn from
each other or I wouldn't do that I
wouldn't have a conversation with a
beginner I want to learn from a native
speaker okay good question I am Japanese
huh speaking in Chinese currently
starting to check the most complicated I
guess yeah I mean since laughing
languages to me dramatically are much
more complicated than Japanese have you
ever tried to practice language that
started with a camera like Moses no why
not matter any person the world can
pronounce any Japanese whoever Mandarin
is more difficult yeah I mean we can
argue at which is more difficult though
difficult in different ways what's your
favorite book in English you know that's
so personal I like history books what
kind of things do you not focus while
listening it's I don't control that I'm
listening and all of a sudden I lose
focus I get focused back again
okay resolute max would it make sense
with rut suddenly what you talked about
it
yeah with Russian of course the problem
not the verbs well it is the verbs of
motion and the aspect of birds but in
terms of endings
it's the nouns and the adjectives and
that's exactly what I did I would look
at the tables and I would say phrases I
would tag the phrases in lane so that I
could so have a concentrated review of
them and I still get the wrong and I'm
hoping now I'm going to Ukraine second
half of May and pretty nice from Ukraine
in Kiev it's mostly Russian and I just
I'm hoping that when I'm you know with
people and speaking Russian then I'm
hearing them speak correctly that I'm
gonna start taking it off but in terms
of things that you can do while reading
and listening I think the idea that you
sort of get a bit of a random but an
isolated look at these things that are
difficult like the cases and it's not
about explanations of cases it's about
actually developing a habit so that you
produce it correctly I think this sort
of isolated random based isolated look
at tables look at phrases is all
contributes to you gradually getting
them better and then when you hear them
in that for conversation that further
reinforces it how good as much friends
need to be to read frizzle
I think first is is is good and you know
it's it's fairly demanding I guess I
mean I didn't read Proust as a beginner
one thing I can say is that Proust is
quite boring to read however when you
hear it as an audiobook which I did I
listened to it as an audiobook it's much
better it's much more pleasant to listen
to there's an audiobook so and I would
go out and get an audiobook and and then
the e-book can import the e-book into
interlink because I I wanted to know
what do you think some people want your
credit when you speak in language
fluently yeah I don't worry about people
like that how would you go about
learning look at me for a book every
session on standardized test
taking your native language you got a
read I mean depending on what the
vocabulary is whether it's broadly based
or medical or economic terms and I we do
a lot of reading in that subject do you
think to beginners nation could learn
from each other no what do you look for
in an online tutor I think I answered
that si special opportunity now because
are they good to learn words sure I'm
sure they worked SRS spaced repetition
systems but it's a question of how much
time you want to spend doing that
activity so in my case not much how do
you expand my English Braille character
from B to C one lots of reading and
listening and expanded you got to decide
they're on expanded need to say
political economic technical literature
and then go find material like that and
I would use audiobooks and ebooks
because then you can look at words and
you can hear it and you can be kind of
reading the book while doing something
else cuz you're listening to it
if a student wants for long time
speaking with a native teacher here
but current and it has no longer kind of
how long do you think the student will
have till he loses because you know you
don't lose the speaking spill it may get
rusty but then if you get a new
opportunity it'll come back pretty
quickly oh okay I'm like someone's
grandpa I can you native speaker in true
four languages I don't think I'm a
native speaker in Iran I read out of a
forum but someone is translated a source
in Catalan I hope so
I I I'm not up to date on that we may
even have Catalan I simply don't know I
do a lot of us names yeah I mean solid
yeah whatever you do in the language is
good it's all good but you do have to
expand your vocabulary past simple words
because the people you'll be talking to
eventually will know more words than you
do and you have to be able to understand
them in order to have conversations well
I'll tell
without using translation you got to
repeat what people say and where they
struggle and use the sickening words
back at them and point and gesticulate
but also when all else fails use
translation how hard would it be learn
polish if you know Russian yeah I think
any of the Slavic languages the biggest
issue for like from Russian to polish is
vocabulary because the grammar is very
similar there are some things that are
different and so I mean it's it's a lot
easier there's no question how the
balance between learning English I
didn't meet a level of French for the
beginning I don't know you'd have to
experiment do you have any suggestions
about improving English writing to write
better you have to read a lot read a lot
reading improves writing listening
improve speaking I struggled to
understand grammar as I say give
yourself a lot of exposure to the
language you know get familiar with it
and then read through those basic books
on the language more listening and
reading read through the basic
instructions again have you got
something to speak there and do you
think Justin Trudeau will lose haha
don't want to get into politics here
have you got something sneaked to speak
better you got to speak a lot nicely
yeah
Elliott Lockwood reading and listening
it's amazing how powerful how simple how
easy it is to do and how effective it is
Brazilian Portuguese speaker who speaks
six languages then think about learning
my first Asian language I love all of
them so which one would be easier to
start with I mean I don't know about
easier but you know to me Chinese is the
one because you've got to get out the
characters now Asian languages of course
there's the East Asian languages which
are very much influenced by Chinese and
then there's Indonesian or there's Thai
so it's a matter of what you're most
motivated to learn
that arise that his policy of rushing me
is paused
Stan and I sat down hating there's no
such matter is random book carrier that
you would find it well then you just
have to read Brock odd I recently found
her channel started taking interesting
is link worth it if you're asking me of
course I think it's worth it that's
where I learned all my languages other
people may have different comments and
you're talking about more personal
aspects of language learning what works
for you it comes back to what you've
already said about prompt tenets finding
what compels you yes sometimes when I
read a sentence in Chinese all of the
words but I can't seem to understand the
meaning any tips
that's true in all languages and you
just have to you know where is there are
patterns to these languages and the
brain will eventually start to sort
these out and in just a matter of more
exposure and gradually it becomes more
natural okay Pedro Garcia
I mean what's I think yes without
earlier a poco serve our major ah non
English there's no magic okay will you
remember word if you read passages over
as possible I don't do that so does
language learning have a positive role
in strengthening our cognitive mental
and abilities I think it does but I have
no proof of that
I'm not a cognitive scientist but it's
it's a good positive things thing to do
thank you rushing with max we should
chat sometime
is this a my recommendation is in the
know quite a few Asian ice okay
with that I am going to leave because
it's been a whole hour here so fact
thank you for listening and I will see
you the next time